Hello everyone.
It is August 2, 2023. We're in
the active inference for the Social
Sciences course. I'm Daniel Friedman,
and this is going to be a lecture on
collective behavior. Now of course,
disclaimers could abound and there's so
many ways to go about this topic of
collective behavior that in duality, in
enactment, I really hope it is multi
scale and collective. I'm really looking
forward to your comments and your
engagement with this area, with this
lecture, with this course. So if you're
watching Live, you can add comments into
the live chat or questions and I'll
check them out at the end. Also in the
YouTube live chat and in the video
description, there is a link to where
you can submit questions for all of the
teachers of this course. That's going to
be a coda form. And just more generally,
let's have fun enacting ecosystems of
shared intelligence together. And I hope
that this lecture can be something like
one attempt to make that happen.
epistemically, we're going
to have many fun things to talk about
collective behavior. What differentiates
it from simply behavior? I mean, aren't
all behaving systems assemblages? Is not
the brain composed of multiple parts,
brain and body, multiple people? What
are we really talking about with
individual behavior? Why do we need
adjectives at all for behavior? What is
a collective and how would we even know
it except through its behavior? So
there's going to be all kinds of fun
topics.
Avel provided me with this image and
suggested that it would be a great place
to head towards. And so we can think of
this as where we're going. And where
we're going is understanding the agent
or the human in a social
relationship through social action and
the recipient of social constraints and
observations through that interface or
blanket or holographic screen, the agent
or the human is engaging on this
sociocultural landscape. And so we can
think about that agent of engagement
with a social world and the dynamic of
sociocultural constraints. Now that's
where we're going, and that's how
someone else has framed where we're
going. What I'll tell you here is how
we're getting there, how we're getting
there. It's going to be a lot of fun.
There's going to be a lot of ants, and
the door is going to be wide open. So
everyone is an estimate on this slide
and we're going to be with our regimes
of attention and our stigmaergic trails
just absolutely up, down, left, right,
all over this sociocultural landscape.
All right, so here's the plan for the
collective behavior lecture. It's going
to be presented as a sequence of views.
Each view or perspective is going to
consist of at very least a central
citation and then one or more
reflections on that citation.
Four views on collective behavior taken
as a bundle will constitute a main
section of this lecture. And there are
going to be three main sections of this
lecture split on one hand into three
groups of four and on the other hand
into two groups of six splitting
into fours. The main three sections are
going to be background and Context,
which is going to provide some views and
insights that are from outside of active
inference because surprise, surprise,
what was true before active inference or
outside of active inference is also true
within and after. Then we're going to
turn to active inference. Specifically,
we're going to talk about active
inference insights and fundamentals for
collective behavior and applications and
implications of utilizing or of
conceptualizing of a social system as an
active inference system. So those second
two sections are each going to center
around also specific recent work in the
field to split it into two groups
of six. The first six views that are
presented so all of background and
context and then half of the insights
and fundamentals are going to be in
support linguistically or rhetorically
of a declarative statement, whereas the
latter six views are going to support
or open up to a question. And that'll
lead us to the final section, the fourth
section, which is some open questions.
At that time, I will look at the live
chat and review any questions or
thoughts that people have. And I'll also
just open the door and leave it open
with asking questions, because that's
something that we're going to be engaged
in for so long. So let's go
right into the first section,
background and context. Here are the
four views and the four declarative
statements. Big picture.
Many, if not all of the concepts,
discussions, questions and views on
collective behavior from before or
outside of active inference also apply
after or inside active inference or in
the active inference ecosystem. And so
to support and to build out that point,
I'm going to talk about four different
works and some takeaways. First,
watching behavior is complex. Here we'll
look at Deborah Gordon's 1992 paper.
Wittgenstein and Ant watching.
Second, all intelligence is Collective
Intelligence, which was a presentation
of the same name by J. F. Klaudier
earlier this year, referencing a paper
of the same name. Third. We have never
been individuals. A work by Gilbert et
al. From 2012, A Symbiotic View of Life
we Have Never Been Individuals, little
bit of the play on we have never been
modern and the metaphors
and frameworks and language that we use
to talk about behavior, to talk about
collective behavior, what adjectives we
put in front of, what nouns, that
matters. And a great work that Ali
shared with me that I think makes this
point super well is by Navarro and
Gabriellitis from 23. And that work
is the morphology of collective
intelligence. Network swarm, multitude
or assemblage. So let's head straight to
Professor Gordon's 1992 work on
Wittgenstein and Ant Watching. And so
just also for context, professor Gordon
was my PhD advisor and so I was able to
engage with this material and
perspective through asynchronous means
such as this paper, but also seeing it
actually play out on a sociocultural
landscape in the desert in southeast
Arizona. That's where the complexity
really flowered. And so research
in animal behavior begins by identifying
what animals are doing in the course of
observation. The observer comes to see
animals as performing a particular
activity. How does this process work?
How can we be certain that behavior is
identified correctly? Wittgenstein
offers an approach to these questions,
looking at the uses of certainty rather
than attempting to find rules that
guarantee it. Here, two stages in
research are distinguished. First,
watching animals, and second, reporting
the results to other scientists.
Certainty about what animals are doing
has different uses at each stage. And
this is really a beautiful and subtle
point by distinguishing stages
of the ethological encounter, the
behavioral scientific encounter,
whether we're talking about ants on the
ground or people in the cities,
separating out the observational moment
and the uncertainties that are always at
play there from this secondary
communication about behavior at which
point having really clear defined
articulations of behavior becomes so
important for scientific
reproducibility, integrity,
accessibility and so on. Personally,
I find that this paper anticipates a lot
of the specifications that today we
would consider part of the metabasian
perspective, which is to say we're
making inferences as cognitive systems
about other cognitive systems.
She wrote, My questions about ant
watching do not arise when I'm watching
ants. Most of the time, I do not think
much about certainty when ant watching.
Replace that for the social human
setting with people watching. Sometimes
we're just watching people, and that's
okay. That's part of the moment. I do
not think much about certainty when ant
watching. I enact it.
The questions do not come from doubts
about the certainty of my seeing, but
from the ways that doubts about the
certainty of seeing have shaped
scientific practice. The resolution of
the problem would come from changes that
would allow observers to talk about what
they are actually doing when watching
animals. Truthful accounts of scientific
animal watching don't yet exist. This
truth is not yet formed because we have
not yet learned to talk about it.
What a wonderful expression and
delightfully. I came to see the confused
foragers as patrollers searching for new
food. I saw the other foragers as
already decided about their destination,
not available to be distracted by a new
source of food. And so we have this
really fascinating dialectic where in
the moment we're observing in this
predefinitional space. Not questioning,
though maybe we went to the field site
to ask and answer a question, get data
about a question. But in the moment,
we're in the flow of observation and not
asking questions, though the uncertainty
may be the highest afterwards when
we're communicating to our scientific
colleagues. I defined an outgoing
forager as a forager as
a nest mate with no object in the
mandibles and heading off in a straight
line passing a demarcated .3
meters from the colony entrance, then
people, well, why 3 meters? Why not 2
meters? Or why can't it be carrying
something on the way out? Those
questions arise in that precise space
of communication. And I
wanted to open the lecture with this
view because it puts a space between.
I see that person putting out a fire.
They're a firefighter. In that space
between is the interpretive moment and
possibility. And reimagining the social
has so much to do with this process of,
let's just say, ant watching.
Second view in this background and
context section. And here I wanted to
draw from a wonderful presentation that
JF. Cloutier, a facilitator and
participant at the Active Inference
institute, presented as part of his
robotics and embodied project, where,
yes, he's building Lego robots that do
symbolic active inference, but also
opening up some great philosophical
directions and ones that have a lot of
implications for how we think about
natural, artificial and synthetic
intelligence. This presentation was
called All Intelligence is Collective
Intelligence, and it was based upon the
title and drawing upon a
recent 2022 citation by Fallon Days et
al. And some of these maxims
or expressions that JF provided,
I thought were so provocative and also
brought us back to that initial
question, why collective behavior? I
mean, what system isn't a collective?
So why do we need the adjective if we're
talking about behaving systems? What is
individual behavior? Individual what?
Oh, just one bird. Oh, just one person.
Okay. Made up of what?
And so JF wrote some expressions, and
you can see from the link and look a
little more with some images and more of
what he wrote. But a few of these, I
thought, were just excellent.
Intelligence is a process enacted by
interacting parts, not a property of
individuals. Again, whatever that would
even mean. Inaction is death.
Being by doing action without prediction
is reckless. No prediction without sense
making. No sense made without a self
versus the world or a self in the world.
A collective is differently intelligent
than its members. Maybe trivially
different, maybe better in every way,
maybe another direction in every way.
Why do individuals participate in
collectives? Why are people in groups?
Because sacrificing the autonomy to
the collective provides benefit,
survival, or even thrival benefits
that's that I to we no
making of sense without the self acting
in or on the world. It's not just some
essence that's disembodied. This is what
embodiment is all about. An autonomous
agent is a self organizing collective of
parts. Parts of a collective can
themselves be autonomous agents.
Collectives form to improve the chance
of survival of their members. And an
agent in a collective benefits from the
intelligence of the collective. So to
me, this presentation and line of
research pursued by JF and others
absolutely puts a bow on the what is an
individual, what is a collective? Why do
we even talk about, quote,
individuals or quote collectives
when we recognize the multiscale nature
of complex adaptive systems.
Third Perspective a
Symbiotic view of Life we have never
been individuals. This is a 2012 paper
by Gilbert, SAP and Tower and
just to read a few aspects of what they
wrote in the abstract. The notion of the
biological individual is crucial to
studies of genetics, immunology,
evolution, develop anatomy and
physiology. Each of these biological
subdisciplines has a specific conception
of individuality which has historically
provided conceptual context for
integrating newly acquired data.
Few descriptions animals cannot be
considered individuals by anatomical or
physiological criteria because a
diversity of symbionts are both present
and functional in completing metabolic
pathways and serving other physiological
functions. Similarly, these new studies
have shown that animal development is
incomplete without symbionts. Symbionts
also constitute a second mode of genetic
inheritance providing selectable genetic
variation for natural selection which
connects it to the evolutionary concept
of an individual. So if we pursue the
metabolic oh, it's all the metabolic
networks and how they're all connected.
That's the individual. All right. Well,
that includes the microbiome and
symbionts. Well, no, it's the physiology
and the decision making and the
neurophysiology. Those are also in play
with the symbionts. Well, at least
evolution only selects upon the germ
line, right? Well, no, actually there
are these multiple mechanisms of
inheritance whether they're relevant in
a given situation or not is situational.
But in principle they exist and they're
increasingly coming to be recognized.
Additionally for the immune system
commonly described as quote, self versus
non self or self identification or self
other discrimination. After all, we talk
about autografting and allografting.
But of course there are aspects of
quote, self or self under some
definitions like an epitope from a
protein in cartilage that an autoimmune
disorder might target. So the immune
system is mobilized against self under
some definitions sometime and is not
mobilized against other under some
definitions sometimes. Like we're not
constantly mounting a massive immune
response to our gut microbiome. Our skin
microbiome, recognizing the holobiont,
the multicellular Eukaryote, plus its
colonies of persistent symbionts as a
critically important unit of anatomy,
development, physiology, immunology and
evolution and cognition, opens up a new
investigative avenue and conceptually
challenges the ways in which the
biological subdisciplines have
heretofore characterized living
entities. Here we have the COVID of the
famous work Leviathan. It's a large
person constituted of other people
really making the point clear. But if we
zoomed in on, quote, an individual
person wouldn't we find something like
societies of cells? What is an
individual? When is an individual?
What and what's on the line?
I thought those are such big questions.
Maybe could we connect it to a little
bit of more of a bibliographic piece of
data just to show a snapshot and to open
up this discussion to you all about
what's on the line with what's an
individual. And so what I did is I
searched for some literature trends on
PubMed and here is the results per
100,000 citations for collective
behavior. And so we see collective
behavior first being mentioned in the
1950s, at least in this literature
database, and rising up on through
around 500 or 400 or 500 per hundred
thousand. So 1000 out of 100,000 would
be 1%. So half of a percent of
all the citations on a major biolytic
literature database had
collective behavior in them. So that's a
huge amount of work, and it looks like
it goes down. But when you actually look
at how many citations there are, it's
been about 4000 publications per year.
It's just that the rest of the
literature database may be expanding at
a faster rate. So thousands of papers
per year and an appreciable fraction of
work has to do with collective behavior.
And so I thought, wow, that's exciting,
that's great. Well, how are we doing
compared to behavior? Now, collective
behavior is this lower line in red.
And yeah, there's a Blip, but behavior
is up between 15 and 20% of
citations in PubMed. Now, maybe behavior
is also referring to the behavior of a
given material that may or may not be a
superconductor or might be using
different understandings of behavior.
But what can we say and what can we know
about the difference between individual
and collective behavior? Now,
interestingly, here I searched for
individual behavior as a specific term,
so we see a lot lower. But individual
behavior, I mean, can the tide
have already turned? Can it really be
the case that after 2020, this is a real
meaningful decline? I don't know. It's
too early to say. We can't do technical
analysis just like that, but very
provocative and gives us some ways to
look at the broader scale or collective
scientific cognitive process associated
with these incredibly important
philosophical and biological
questions about individuality. Because,
of course, to distinguish collective
behavior from individual behavior, or
why would you even need an adjective at
all? It's going to come down to what is
an individual and what's on the line so
much. And the last view here,
drawing upon the work morphology of
collective intelligence network, swarm,
multitude, or assemblage? And Tony
Devorrow and Alejandro Lopez Gabrielis
wrote, network, swarm and multitude are
some of the different metaphors that
have been used to understand the concept
of collective intelligence. All of them
have reflected our relationship with the
Internet and its development. With the
advent of artificial intelligence AI,
we wonder about other metaphors that
might offer a new understanding of
collective intelligence to address
today's environmental and sociotechnical
challenges. They bring up network,
swarm and multitude to advocate for
the fourth option assemblage.
Understanding collective intelligence as
an assemblage allows for the inclusion
of different human and technological
agents and overcomes the
anthropocentrism human centrism human
exclusionism of other models based on
human will, whether extended as in the
multitude or suppressed as in the swarm
connotations here. In this way, ethical
decision making and responsibility are
distributed among different cognitive
actors with the capacity to choose and
interpret. And to the extent that they
make decisions, albeit algorithmic ones,
they are also accountable. And I love
this, and I think it foreshadows where
we're going to be going with active
inference, which is different
cognitive actors have the capacity to
choose and interpret. We might connect
that to sensory and internal states of
an active inference agent. But
perception, sense making, signal
processing inbound information and
decision making and responsibility and
accountability and the accountability
that we associate with human
sociotechnical systems, that's the
action selection, control theory,
outgoing dependencies in the Markov
blanket. So right there, coming from
outside of active inference, we see the
identification of the need to have
flexible frameworks, including
linguistic and metaphorical, that allow
us to talk about heterogeneous diverse
cyberphysical systems where different
entities are engaged in different
practices and ways of incoming sense
making and outgoing decision making.
And it's going to turn out that active
inference is an incredible and flexible
expressive framework that's going to
allow us to talk about those kinds of
systems pointed to here. And it really
matters. They point to some of the most
important aspects of issues today
on to active inference, insights and
fundamentals. Well, here, as in all the
other areas, there were so many pieces
of literature that could have been drawn
on. That's why I restricted myself to
just four views.
Also, this section is going to mark the
midway point. We're not there yet,
don't worry, but the midway point of the
lecture where we move from the six
declarative expressions onto the
questions because it's more open than
not and there's more space for you to
respond than you may imagine. But the
view is going to be here. And what are
the literature that support that point?
So, first, active inference in the free
energy principle, which is a principle
that provides a lot of theoretical
grounding and physics based perspective
on active inference. But we're not going
to go too much into it today. Active
inference and the free energy principle
are scale free formalisms for cognitive
systems with collectives, as with
individuals, the general framing in
itself does very little. However, with
properly constructed generative models,
we can get explanation, prediction,
design, influence, and implementation
tools. And here I'm going to draw on two
pieces of work epistemic Communities
under Active Inference by Mahault and
colleagues in 2022 and just from several
days ago, the work by Connor Hines and
colleagues. Collective behavior from
surprise minimization. We'll unpack the
point more when we get there. Second,
collectives can be understood as
consisting of action perception loops
which subsume, entail, or supervene upon
individual level action perception
loops, niche modification, stigma,
g can also be modeled this way. We'll
draw upon the paper Active Inference,
an active inference framework for ant
colony behavior by myself and colleagues
in 2021. And then we'll move into the
questions and things will start to open
up. So if it feels like we've been
climbing uphill. We're two thirds of the
way with the uphill climb. Feels like
we've been going downhill. We're two
thirds of the way with a downhill how do
the concepts of generalized synchrony
and homeostasis, which are so core to
active inference, relate to collective
behavior? Here we'll discuss the work by
Ralph Kaufman et al. From 2021, an
active inference model of collective
intelligence. And lastly, in this
section, how can active inference be
used to explore the balance between
individual and collective behaviors and
the bi directional influence of
collectives on individuals, and, of
course, vice versa? Here we'll draw upon
the computational boundary of a self
developmental bioelectricity drives,
multicellularity and scale free
cognition by Mike Levin in 2019.
So let's get right into the work by
Mahault and Connor and colleagues.
First, I'm just going to bring this
paper up. However, first you
can watch more about it in Guest stream
17.1 from March 2022.
Here's two collectives right here. And
also Mahault will be covering this work
in a lot more detail later on in the
course. I just wanted to bring it up
because I think it's one of the
exceptional examples that can be
deployed to show like, hey, just
thinking about the social as an active
inference system is awesome. It's an
intuition pump. It brings us into the
active inference ecosystem. But then
what do we do when we're there? And what
we do when we're there is we develop
generative models that actually take us
towards where we want to be.
Again, framing a situation as
being related to active inference. Or
you could do an active inference model
of that does very, very little work
by itself. However, making generative
models of situations, even if they're
speculative generative models or
qualitative or hypothetical, that can
start getting towards doing work. But if
someone said, well, that health
condition, you could do a linear
regression. Okay, but which treatment do
we do? Well, it could be done with a
linear regression. We could use a linear
regression to figure out what method to
use. Okay, but more or less hotter
room or colder room. Well, just use a
linear regression. So that's the
conversation that we're having a lot
with active inference. A lot of times
people are talking about whether a given
situation can or cannot be modeled with
active inference. Or, just in the
abstract, what does active inference say
about this situation? And again, the
framework itself is general to the point
of doing little work, and we love it
that way. It enables us to move into
systems of interest and deploy
generative models. So what they did in
this paper was leverage the active
inference framework to provide an in
silicon model on the computer chip model
of confirmation bias and its effect on
echo chamber formation. They had a
system of interest people's social
engagement on so called social media,
and they had even a phenomena of
interest which was echo chamber
formation. They built a model based on
active inference where agents tend to
sample information in order to justify
their own view of reality, something we
call self evidencing. We show that once
agents have reached a certain level of
certainty about their beliefs, it
becomes very difficult to get them to
change their views. The system of self
confirming beliefs is upheld and
reinforced by the evolving relationship
between an agent's beliefs and
observations, which will, over time,
will continue to provide evidence for
their ingrained ideas about the world.
Well, where I'm from, we drive on the
right side of the road and so you drive
on the right side of the road, I drive
on the right side of the road. We're not
going to have an issue. Everywhere I
look, I see cars moving around, I see
people passing on the right, on the
sidewalk. It's all making sense. We're
bounding surprise. We're doing active
inference. Surprising minimization
goals, reward never need to come into
play to give an account of how those
systems could arise and be stabilized.
These epistemic communities are
consolidated by those shared beliefs and
in turn tend to produce perceptions of
reality that reinforce those shared
beliefs. And on the top right is just a
little teaser of what a Bayesian
graphical model looks like of the kind
that they deployed in this paper.
And here we see some of the results from
their parameter sweeping, exploring
different combinations of parameters and
looking at topics like polarization
index and reattenance rate and
so all kinds of statistics that can be
drawn upon, connected to the generative
model and also all kinds of
opportunities and interfaces to relate
this to empirical data as well as
suggest experiments. So Mahault is going
to talk more about this and it's awesome
work. And then late breaking news only
several days ago, five or so days ago,
an amazing new pre [unk]print was put up
by Connor Hines and colleagues and it
was just too cool not to include here
and reflects the very rapid pace of
collaborative development in the active
inference ecosystem. And this is their
work collective behavior from surprise
minimization. And they made every point
I wanted to make here and now.
Collective motion is ubiquitous in
nature. Typically, such macroscopic
patterns arise from decentralized local
interactions among constituent
components e. G, individual fish in a
school there's that word individual
again. Preeminent models of this process
describe individuals as self propelled
particles, subject to self generated
motion and social forces such as short
range repulsion and long range
attraction or alignment.
However, organisms are not particles.
They are probabilistic decision makers.
They're cognitive particles. We
introduce an approach to modeling
collective behavior based on active
inference. This cognitive framework
casts behavior as the consequence of a
single imperative to minimize surprise.
Again, if you want to, you can contrast
that with reward learning, where the
imperative is to maximize reward in
active inference and the free energy
principle. We're taking a path of least
action not the laziest path or the most
passive one, but a little bit more
technically a path of least action.
And we're minimizing surprise. We're
bounding surprise with variational free
energy and it turns out that that helps
us minimize surprise and maximize model
evidence. And it can include things like
novelty and curiosity seeking very
naturally. So this doesn't mean we're
squeezing the juice out of life at all.
We demonstrate that many empirically
observed collective phenomena including
cohesion milling and directed motion
emerge naturally when considering
behavior as driven by active Bayesian
inference without explicitly building
behavioral rules or goals into
individual agents. No reward,
no goal, no master of the collective.
Furthermore, we show that active
inference can recover and generalize the
classical notion of social forces as
agents attempt to suppress prediction
errors that conflict with their
expectations. By exploring the parameter
space of the beliefbased model we reveal
nontrivial relationships between the
individual beliefs and group properties
like polarization and the tendency to
visit different collective states. We
also explore how individual beliefs
about uncertainty, metacognition beliefs
about beliefs determine collective
decision making accuracy. What if when
you voted or shared your perspective on
what we were going to have for dinner
you also conveyed an uncertainty
estimate? How confident are you about
that being the case?
Finally, we show how agents can update
their generative model over time
resulting in groups that are
collectively more sensitive to external
fluctuations and encode information more
robustly. From a distributed systems
perspective you could imagine two
different kinds of distributed systems
or networks. One of them has a dampening
like quality. So something that enters
on one side dampens as it diffuses.
We can also contrast that with another
kind of distributed system or another
kind of input or stimulus or context
that amplifies. And the goal
or one nice property to have of systems
would be like we want to dampen what we
don't want to pay attention to and up
signal or increase the cascading
availability of what we do want to
attend to. Now that's a little circular
since in some ways that's the definition
of attention. However, making unified
models like they do here gives us
integrated approaches to explore
a broad range of collective phenomena
here in spatial movement but also
involving the cognitive states of the
particles. And they make a really nice
representation here to connect to other
approaches. A traditional approach to
classical self propelled particles is
agent environment. Agents take rules and
they make decisions based upon those
rules that are either given or learnt.
When you're this close to the bird next
to you, do that and when you're this
close, do this. And then social forces
are these kind of as if or actual
constraints that then modify the agent's
perspective. And what we see in the
active inference setting is that the
agent and the environment are mediated
by an interface. The Markov blanket.
This is. The sensorium. This is on the
inbound side perception and on the
outbound side action. And they give
some more details. It's a really
exciting paper and it's just cool to see
again that even in the preparatory days
of a lecture like this, there's always
new collective activity in the ecosystem
and that's what makes it fun.
Last of the declarative sections of this
lecture. Colonies here,
but more generally collectives, can be
understood as consisting of action
perception loops which subsume, entail
or supervene upon individual level
action perception loops, niche
modifications or stigma. G can also be
modeled this way. What we did in this
paper was bring something new
to active inference in at least two
different ways. First, it was the first
model of an ant system of interest.
Now, for some of us mere mycologists in
the audience, all of our broader
entomology colleagues, that may be
enough. But what was also really
interesting about this work and the
opportunity to collaborate on it, was it
was the first active inference model
presented with explicit stigmaji. Not
just the philosophical consideration of
the traces that agents leaving in the
environment might then have them change
their behavior in the future, but
explicitly engaging with this process of
multiagent stigmurgic behavior.
Active inference may be informative in
the study of ant colonies at three
distinct temporal scales. Nest mate
behavior, which is to say emergent among
tissues of a nest mate, you could keep
on going collectively down and
interactions with the biotic or abiotic
environment. So, first level at the
level of a nest mate, one of those
things with six legs that looks like an
insect, at the level of the colony,
colony development is emergent among
nest mates and their interactions with
the niche. That is where many people
would traditionally assign collective
behavior. They say, well, one nest mate
walking around is individual behavior,
that's the individual ants. And then the
colony is where collective behavior
comes into play, right? And we're going
to see that reified very soon. But
lastly, we point to the evolution of
populations, which is an emergent
outcome amongst colonies within an
ecology. In this work, we focused on the
connection between the first two levels
of analysis, focusing on the case of
stigmergic colony foraging using a
modification of previous active
inference computational implementations.
We didn't use the word individual and
there's a reason why. Because we're
saying what we mean more clearly when
talking about ants, when we talk about
nest mates, colonies and populations of
colonies that sidesteps or
transcends the discussion of what is an
individual and what is a collective.
Because with respect to the colony as an
individual, if you want to use that
word, the population is a collective
with respect to the nest mate, the
colony is a collective. With respect to
the tissue like the brain or the mid
gut, the nest mate is a collective. So
we don't need to play the adjective
game. We can just articulate what we're
interested in about these systems of
interest and complex adaptive system
phenomena. And so what we did was we
explored a kind of classical behavioral
setting which is food being placed
between the arms of a teammates and in
this case, rather than a rat.
I'm just pausing for a second while I
believe that my internet
is reconnecting and we should be back.
Each ant was described by an action
perception loop, an active inference
action perception loop. And they were
able to move within a three by three
grid as well as perceive pheromone
density within a three by three grid.
And then they laid down pheromone, they
added stigmaergic trace on the way home
if they had found a seed. And so this
does a few interesting things and
livestream 29 is where we unpack this a
lot more. But I just wanted to make two
more points here. The first is that in a
reward centric perspective on ant
behavior, the pheromone is seen as a
semiotic queue and the seed or the food
is seen as the reward. And so then we
got to use the cues, we got to use the
pheromone density to figure out where
the good stuff is. That's that paradigm.
We flipped that with active inference.
Now, the preference we don't need to say
reward, but the preference, that which
is sought after proximally but
teleologically, that which is sought
after preferred over is the pheromone.
The seed becomes the semiotic cue that
it's time to turn on your pheromone
depositing and come home. And so that
flips our approach to understanding what
foraging is about from we're lost in the
sauce, trying to figure out where the
good thing is out there to we're surfing
the 100 foot wave and we'll know it when
we see it, and then we'll turn around.
Very different perspective. And then one
other point that I had to make for the
context was that we used a modification
of a previous active inference
computational implementation. What was
the paper that we drew from?
In fact, it was the acquisition of
culturally patterned attention styles
under active inference with Axel and
Alex et al. And what this paper did was
they looked at the situation of visual
foraging on
a vase, a piece of pottery,
where the eye was only able to perceive
a three by three matrix of pixels.
And then the eye scanned around looking
to recognize broader patterns that were
then culturally acquired. So maybe one
culture or one subculture likes the
checkerboard pattern and another one
likes vertical lines, another one likes
horizontal lines or these other kinds of
repetitive structures. What's so
interesting is that the eye, when it is
foraging, does not leave a trace,
though it can feel like it, doesn't it?
But the eye forges around in order to
get the bigger picture based on local
information. What we did is we said,
well, instead of imagining that as the
gaze location of an eye. Let's imagine
that as the skin in the game exoskeleton
on the ground of a forager. So let's
think about that movement as something
that an embodied forager does with its
real body and then conditional
in this setting upon it touching the
seed or the food, it can lay down a
pheromone trail, which the eyes can't do
per se. And so just really interesting
because it's not like this was an ant
paper and now we're going to try to cram
it into social sciences. It's actually
like computational work in the social
sciences was able to translate to
Mirmacology into ants research. And so
it's a very fruitful and bi directional
relationship between studying ants and
studying people.
Now we're going to move into the
openness of questions in this second
half of the lecture. So how
do the concepts of generalized synchrony
and homeostasis, which are core to
active inference, relate to collective
behavior? And here we can draw upon the
work by Ralph Kaufman, Pranav Gupta and
Jacob Taylor from 2021 called inactive
inference model of collective
intelligence. And this was also unpacked
in Gestream Nine. And so here's a little
collective over here. And that was about
two years ago, way back when what
they did in this paper was they
considered a setting with two trolley
cars moving around a wheel.
And so here's how they contextualize
that work. Formal models of collective
intelligence have lacked a plausible
mathematical description of the
relationship between local scale
interactions between autonomous
subsystem components individuals and
global scale behavior of the composite
system, the collective. So they do a
really great job staking out what they
mean by individual and collective.
In this paper, we use the active
inference formulation AIF, a framework
for explaining the behavior of any non
equilibrium steady state system at any
scale deposit, a minimal agent based
model that simulates the relationship
between local individual level
interaction and collective intelligence.
Then they had a really creative approach
to disentangling how different
capacities translated to different
collective outcomes. And here's what
they did. We explore the effects of
providing baseline active inference
agents. Model one with specific
cognitive capabilities,
model two added in a theory of mind,
model three added in goal alignment,
and model four added both theory of mind
and goal alignment. What does that look
like? Again, we're not going to go into
all the technical details here, but
broadly, this is what it looked like.
Here was their simplest baseline active
inference formulation case. And then in
the subsequent experiments, they added
in either one or the other or both of
the cognitive capacities that they
described. They studied the
single DIAD case and
they very cleverly expanded that into
a large scale multidiad
case. They utilized
their own representation of the octave
inference partition in order to
facilitate the construction of this
model. And so in this case, we see the
blanket with the sensory states coming
in, the active states going out. Markov
blanket. Here we see the environment
and then internal belief states or
cognitive states. So very
cool work that helps us get
a vocabulary around, not shut the book
on, but focus on.
How do different agents come to
synchronize? What is generalized
synchrony? Well, it doesn't mean
Lockstep turntaking is generalized
synchrony, because these two agents,
the time that they're talking, has very
high mutual information on the other,
even though the correlation with their
speaking might be negative, agent A is
speaking when B is not, and vice versa.
So from a linear regression perspective,
there's a negative correlation. But from
a mutual information perspective, where
you can't ever have below zero
information, at worst it's just noise.
You always have zero or positive amount
of information of systems about other
systems. And so that opens the door to
understanding generalized synchrony,
which is a broader conception of how
individuals and collectives are
interacting. And homeostasis. Maybe we
could even imagine that these are
multiple cells in the pancreas and
they're trying to coordinate on insulin
sensitivity. Or maybe this is multiple
people who are securing the defense of a
community and they also need to
coordinate synchronously and
asynchronously. And so there's a lot of
ways in which this very, very
lightweight apparatus of the active
inference partition helps us bring
together and compose all these cool.
What ifs? Well, what if it had theory of
mind? What if it had goal alignment?
What if agents had theory of mind and
goal alignment? What if we put them in a
five x seven grid and then we did this
and and that's what we get to do with
active inference. And lastly here,
how can active inference be used to
explore the balance between individual
and collective behavioral and the bi
directional influence of collectives on
individuals? And so here I draw upon the
amazing and singular work of Professor
Mike Levin, who wrote the computational
boundary of a self developmental
bioelectricity drives multicellularity
and scale free cognition in 2019. This
was also explored in Livestream 25
series. So, just to pull out a few of
the great pieces of this article, and
there's a stigmaic trail of many other
papers for those who follow,
professor Levin writes, I propose a
definition of an individual based on its
information processing structure. The
scale and types of goals that a system
can pursue, defines or determines the
boundaries and the content of the
putative agent. On this view,
what defines a coherent, unified self
out of its constituents, components and
the surrounding environment is the set
of parts that operate towards reaching
specific goal states. So this is
a teleological or a functional or
anticipatory or sentient or adaptive or
informational concept on individuals,
which we can add to the earlier
consideration raised by Gilbert et al.
Here they discuss some of the more
mechanistic biological considerations
like genetics, immunology, evolution,
development, anatomy, and physiology.
What Levin has done here, and consistent
with this, is the informational theory
of individuality by David Krakauer et
al. Is connect this more generally to
system capacity. And so there is what is
here represented as like a time diamond,
where the scope or the scale of the
system in the now is like the radius
or the circumference on this diamond.
And then the part of the diamond that
recedes off into the past, that's
retained from the past, is memory and
history. And the part that advances or
pretends into the future is the
anticipatory or the planning capacity.
This opens the door to describing
diverse intelligences, including
possible alien artificial intelligence
or synthetic intelligences, as well as
nested or compound intelligences. So
here the example is the ant colony.
So here we have cells, these little
pinkish diamonds nested
within a nest mate,
which is the green diamond nested within
the colony, which is the blue diamond.
Now, notice that the nest mate is called
an organism. I couldn't help but to
connect this to Wheeler 1911, whose work
is the Ant Colony as an organism.
Superorganism came later. The
superorganismal framing on the ant
colony reifies the concept that
the nest mate is the individual or the
organism, because why else would you
need to call the colony a superorganism?
I mean, I think colonies are super. I
think it's great to call them whatever
you want to call them, and they probably
don't mind either. But the idea that a
superorganism is composed of other
organisms means that the nest mate is an
organism. Whereas this diagram, in my
perspective, would be as accurate or
more to say nest mate here, because
under different concepts of
organismality, which is to say
individuality, if we want to connect it
there, the colony can be considered as
the organism.
And of the so many other pieces of this
work that are fun to bring out, the way
that Levin clarifies his assumptions
gives us, first off, some planks that we
can jump off of for good and helps us
come to terms with maybe like, what do
we assume about behavior, about
collective behavior? How do we want to
show up when we're studying collective
behavior in general and when we're
studying social behavior? After all,
we're in active inference for the social
sciences. And so Levin writes, the ideas
are explored here from the perspective
of the following three core assumptions.
First is a commitment to evolution.
Every capacity has a natural history and
emerged from simpler variants. Second,
it is assumed that all metaphors are to
be judged by their utility in driving
scientific progress. There is not a
binary categorization of scientific
pictures which should be taken literally
or not, which can be decided a priori
upfront. Third, much of the discussion
centers around goals related to
teleology. A hotly debated topic here,
goal directedness is taken in the
nonmagical cybernetic engineering and
control theory sense of a feedback
system that operates to maximize some
specific state of affairs, which can be
modeled as a dynamical system with
attractors in its state space. And later
work by Levin and Fields and others
expanded this concept of intelligence
just to phenomenal heights and flavors.
So active inference helps us understand
that cognitive glue maybe it's
mechanistically enacted by
bioelectricity in a given system or at a
given scale, but active inference gives
us the analytical glue to approach those
systems with an open mind and
an open scaffold. And so those are
some of the insights and fundamentals of
active inference as applied to
collective behavioral systems. Now on to
the last third of this lecture
applications and Implications of Active
Inference for the Social Sciences
regarding collective behavior. This is
really where it is wide, wide, wide
open. What kinds of
insights can active inference offer
about the role of learning, adaptation,
conflict, and cooperation in collective
behavior? And how can we approach that
from a cognitive security perspective?
Here we'll draw on the work of Scott
David and colleagues, active Inference
in Modeling Conflict what implications
does active inference have on the study
of human collective behavior,
particularly in social, economic, and
digital contexts? Here we'll draw on the
work by Poirier et al.
Communication as socially extended
active inference. An ecological approach
to communicative behavior livestream.
48 series what
considerations that are relevant for
thinking about assemblages and
interactions? What considerations are
relevant for thinking about assemblages
and interactions among different
entities in cognitive ecosystems? Here
we'll turn to the work of Friston et al.
Et al. 2022, designing Ecosystems
of Intelligence from First Principles
and how does active inference
accommodate collective behavior within
and across generations? And here we'll
look at a variational synthesis of
evolutionary and developmental dynamics
by Friston et al. In 2023.
So when it comes to applications and
implications of active inference in
social sittings and settings, again,
there's so much to do, there's so much
to learn. So we welcome everybody who's
curious. This is the time to write your
live chats, submit your questions,
prepare yourself to explore, and to be
an active forager in this space. And if
you're listening, you know that you
already are. So in the work. Active
inference in modeling conflict. Scott.
David RJ. Corday and myself asked
what kinds of insights can active
inference offer about the role of
learning, adaptation, conflict and
cooperation in collective behavior?
Now, as with all these other papers,
there's always so many things that can
be said. What we did is we tried to
connect beyond the very classical Markov
blanket and agent environment
partitioning, which we've seen many,
many times. We tried to connect this to
the specific kind of generative models
that we use in modeling. So here
we led early by clarifying, this is what
we're talking about with active
inference, generative models. It's not
like something I'm hiding in my pocket
and maybe I'll show you if you say the
shibolith. This is what we're talking
about when we're talking about applying
active inference models to social
settings. It's a discrete time
generative model here just a motif.
We applied that kind of generative model
architecture to one of the
most well known models of sense making
and decision making, which is the UDA
loop. Observe, orient, decide, act by
John Boyd Now this may seem to some like
a quite sparse framework. Like, yeah,
you get the observation, you figure it
out, you make a decision, you take the
action. It doesn't do that much work
by itself either. However, UDA is used
in tactical and strategic settings every
single day. And so we wanted to connect
OODA loop to the generative models
that we use in active inference. And so
we highlighted on the generative model
where different stages of the OODA loop
occur. Perception happens in the sensory
states. Cognition or the orientation
happens in the perceptual inference,
the downstairs of that part of the
figure. And then decision making happens
in the upstairs with the expected free
energy calculation in this case. And
finally action is selected and enacted
and that results in impact and the cycle
begins again. Now, in active inference
it's more like an unfolding flow, but to
a first pass approximation it does the
trick. Why does that really matter that
we understand the mechanics of decision
making? Well, we're talking about active
inference in the social setting. That
means we're talking about two
sophisticated cognitive entities, maybe
two businesses, maybe two individual
humans, maybe a person and a business,
maybe different kinds of systems that we
don't even know about or we haven't even
seen yet. And that generative model
is the internal states that is then
participating in this minimal dyadic
collective behavioral encounter. We can
expand that to thinking about commons
resource, commons attention, commons
open source ecosystems. And for this
we utilized one of Scott David's
favorite acronyms of which he has so so
many, which is Bolts business,
Operation, Legal, Technical and Social.
Bolts is not an exhaustive acronym,
otherwise we would need everything. But
it's a heuristic that encourages us to
think holistically about different
systems. Let's just say that we were a
business or a person and we wanted to
see if a given policy was a good way to
go to complete our mission. And it
looks good, except it can't be done
operationally. Well then that has to be
taken into account or everything works
out but it's illegal. That's not the way
to go. Everything works out, but the
business doesn't check out. It's not
going to be sustainable financially or
technically it can't be done. Or
socially it's not palatable. All of
these features of sociotechnical
systems, which again we just make a
little mnemonic of with Bolts need to be
taken into account for comprehensive and
high integrity, high reliability systems
design. In this setting we have entity A
and entity B interacting through the
Bolts niche. They each have their own
blanket states sense in action. And the
niche where those nest mates were laying
their pheromones, the niche is bolts.
And so you could make a restricted model
where it's just two entities engaged in
a financial dealing, just a business
only engaging on B. Or you could think
of this multidomain full spectrum
situation in terms of bolts. Then you
would have a larger and a more complex
interface between these two entities.
But we also wanted to think about the
case where there might be cooperation
between these entities or there might be
conflict. And so here we have entity A
and B. The Dyad is in the spotlight.
Entity C is a non belligerent state
or it's a bystander, or it's a witness,
or it's a referee, or it's a friend, or
it's a colleague. But entity C is also
engaging only through their blanket
states on bolts.
And lastly, we connect it to the Abiotic
niche which may not care how much
you're buying or selling a gallon of oil
for. The abiotic niche may have its own
dynamics. We may use active inference to
model that or we might use some other
approach to model it. And so this sets
a really, really general state space for
us to understand conflict and
cooperation and where we situated that
work. Lastly, here was in relationship
to other work exploring strategic
and tactical decision making and so on.
The lower end of this image are tactical
and operational frameworks that are used
in decision making. On the top are
strategic or scholarly frameworks that
are used for more of like geopolitical
considerations. And then from left to
right we have more qualitative
approaches going to more formal and
quantitative approaches. And we believe
that the application of active inference
through this type of model, the active
inference conflict model, helps us touch
the qualitative natural language and
graphical composable aspects and the
quantitative and formal aspects as well.
And similarly, through nested decision
making cycles we can talk about tactical
operational activities and the broader
nested strategy just like we looked at
the nested cones from Professor Levin's
work. Next, what implications
does active inference have on the study
of human collective behavior,
particularly in social, economic and
digital contexts? Well, there's a lot to
say about this, but Tisson and Pore
wrote in 2021 the paper communication as
socially extended active inference, an
ecological approach to communicative
behavior. And this was in the Livestream
48 series. Here's Remy raising
his hand so that we knew that he wanted
to speak. They introduced an ecological
account of communication according to
which acts of communication are active
inference achieved by affecting the
behavior of a target organism via the
modification of its field of
affordances. Constraining a target
organism's behavior constitutes a
mechanism of socially extended active
inference allowing organisms to
proactively regulate their interstates
through the behavior of other organisms.
In this general conception of
communication, the type of cooperative
communication characteristic of human
communicative interaction is a way of
constraining interaction dynamics
towards the goals of a given joint
action by constructing and altering
shared fields of affordances. This
account embraces a pragmatist view,
according to which communication is a
form of action aiming to influence the
behavior of a target and stands against
the traditional transmission view,
according to which communication
fundamentally serves to convey
information. Understanding acts of
communication as active inference under
an ecological interpretation allows us
to link communicative and ultimately
linguistic behavior to the biological
imperative of minimizing free energy and
to emphasize the action oriented nature
of communicative interaction. This is
really a rich and excellent work that
Remy and Pierre produced, and there are
several pieces that I think add a lot of
meaning and value to the ways that we
think about communication. But most
broadly, what is communication for? Who
do we talk to and why? What do we like
to talk about and why? Why would anyone
say that? And why? How does technique,
considered broadly, technology and
technique, whether it's digital or
social or cultural technique, mediate
and influence communication? The media
is the message. The medium is the
message. And think about everything in
that area, too. And how can active
inference, beyond just giving these
incredible composable formal tools, how
can we think about joint action and
co modification of fields of
affordances? Hey, could you pick that up
from that shelf? Okay, I'll open it for
you. Now let's hand it to our friend
who's going to make the food. All of
these ways in which individuals shape
each other's field of affordances is
something that we can talk about really
fluidly within active inference.
Penultimate View what considerations are
relevant for thinking about assemblages
and interactions among different
entities in cognitive ecosystems? So
here was a large multi author paper from
Karl Friston et al. And The Versus
Colleagues designing Ecosystems of
Intelligence from First Principles from
December 2022. And the big picture as I
see it here is what is the role of the
social sciences after all the course
that we're in now in ecosystems of
diverse heterogeneous? Synthetic
intelligences. By synthetic
intelligences, I refer to assemblages
with intelligence, whether it's natural
or artificial. Leave that debate for
another day, because in their
application, we're talking about
synthetic intelligence. Synthetic
intelligence needs cognitive security.
Cognitive security needs cognitive
science. And they began this paper with
the following this white paper presents
active inference as an approach to
research and development in the field of
artificial intelligence. AI artificial
with the aim of developing ecosystems of
natural and artificial intelligences.
The path forward in AI is often
presented as progressing from systems
that are able to solve problems within
one narrow domain, artificial narrow
intelligence ANI to systems that are
able to solve problems in a domain
general manner at or beyond human
levels, what are known as artificial
general intelligence, AGI, and
artificial superintelligence ASI. We
believe that approaching ASI or for
reasons outlined below, even AGI likely
requires an understanding of networked
or collective intelligence. Now,
intelligence in action is behavior. So
we're talking about collective behavior
and they laid out their timeline and the
stages that they see in terms of
sentient, sophisticated, sympathetic and
finally shared intelligences. But I
think it's worth to dwell a moment on
the one figure of this paper.
Figure one belief updating on a
statistical manifold. And so here we
have some curve in an information
geometric space, it's a parameter space
of a probability distribution. And on
this manifold, on this line on
a plane, lower dimensional manifold
projection, there's a temporal
process belief at time t, T plus one, T
plus two, where initially this gaussian
that's very distributed becomes updated
to a sharper peak distribution that's
going to be resting basically at some
special point on this curve.
Whether you're very familiar with
accelerated optimization on information
geometric manifolds or not,
it's really interesting to consider why
they went with this image. And for those
again who are familiar or just coming to
be familiar with some of the formalisms
of active inference, this is what this
very talented and transdisciplinary team
went with when seeking to provide some
of the only nontextual descriptions of
their work. So I think it's really
interesting and the big question is,
well, what is the social reassembling
the social Bruno La Tour, what is the
social? What is social? Does social mean
only adult humans talking with each
other? Does social include non
human species? Does social include non
biological intelligences? These are all
things that are not just questions of
theory. So connecting flexible
extensible frameworks like active
inference and all that comes along with
it to this bigger question about
applications and implications of applied
active inference in the social setting.
That's what I hope we can explore in the
questions at the end of this live stream
and in the discussions that we have in a
couple of weeks and ongoing. And lastly,
how does active inference accommodate
collective behavioral within and across
generations? And so here I'll draw on
the recent work a variational synthesis
of evolutionary and developmental
dynamics with Karl Friston, myself and
others. And we had two images
in this work which otherwise had a lot
of prose and formalism. On the left,
we see that active inference,
particular partition, external states,
internal states, blanket states, here at
the organismal level, one worm,
and in an enested deeper system,
the population, which gives rise
to the starting positionality of the
organisms. Think about drawing an
organism from a gene pool, from a birth
pool and the impact that those organisms
have on the bigger picture,
maybe it's a bacteria that is
fermenting so it changes the PH or the
ethanol concentration of the Kombucha.
That is this kind of multiscale
interaction that we believe
provides an approach to understanding
ecoevo devo, ecology,
evolution and developmental
interactions. And the other
visualization that we use here is of
nested systems. So contrast that with
the kind of time diamond
that we saw from Mike Levin. Now here,
imagine that we're going to cut across
the. Center of this diamond and now it's
going to look like a muscle fiber fibers
of fibers, because we have, let's just
say this outer blue line may
be the colony.
And then each of these smaller entities
is an estimate and they're composed of
cells, and cells have constituents too.
And here we utilized the apparatus
of the renormalization group which draws
upon physics to articulate the
separation of scales. So that we can be
clear when are we talking about
multiscale systems which we can
articulate and renormalize across
vertically to use an encultured
metaphor? And then within a given scale
of analysis, what is the lateral or
collective behavior? So how do we get
those interactions amongst nest mates
that are both constrained by the colony
top down? Again, using a spatial and
encultured metaphor top down scaffolded
or enabled or constrained by the colony.
But then what nest mates do matters and
that influences the colony. And we used
a few new pieces of formalism primarily
developed by Coral to help express that
setting. And again, we think it's going
to be really useful for describing
otherwise quite challenging scenarios in
ecology, evolution and development. And
so we come right back to that what is
a self? What about nested selves?
And with that, I turn to some open
questions. What can be said other
than there are so many open
questions to discuss?
There's many things we can explore in
the discussion that I'll be facilitating
in a couple of weeks. And of course,
beyond we have a coda interface for
you to submit questions that all the
course teachers will take a look at and
give their best attempt on. And
conversation is collective behavior.
Now, sure, keeping it inside of your
head is also collective behavior, no
matter how you think about it. But when
we enact in the social,
then we're really making it happen. So
with that, I will just show my citations
and the slides will be shared too.
Also, there's some extra readings that
various individuals along the way
suggested to me. So that includes social
ecologies and abductive logic enacting
like a state. These are not the titles.
The titles are inactive. Dynamic Social
Cognition and Active Inference. That was
livestream 47 thinking like a state
embodied intelligence in the deep
history of our collective minds. That
Was Livestream 33 Active Inference
applicability to different kinds of
social Organizations explained through
reference to industrial engineering and
quality Management. That was live stream
27 resonating minds emergent
collaboration through hierarchical
active inference. Yellow Broomberg's
and Eric Wrightvel's work on self
organization, free energy minimization
and optimal grip on a field of
affordances. And the well known Thinking
through Other Minds work by Vesier et
al. Thinking through other minds. A
variational approach to cognition and
culture.
Well, I hope this has been an
interesting and relevant lecture for
you. It was fun to prepare.
There are so many perspectives and so
much territory that there's
a lot in collective behavior. But again,
I'm just really looking forward to the
discussion that we can have in a couple
of weeks. I encourage you, whether
you're listening on your timeline and
at a moment that enables you to join
that live conversation, I would
encourage you to join or to join the
live stream so you can participate
through chat or whether you want to find
some other way to get involved. It's
been a great time, and with that, I will
close. Thank you very much. Until next
time.